Megan Margot nobody feels sorry for you
Wendy Williams has no sympathy for Royal
Pains and we've got a lot to talk about
so let's get into it Wendy went off on
her talk show on Tuesday going after the
Dutchess of Sussex aka Megan Markel
after her headline-making interview for
her and her husband Prince Harry's ITV
documentary you talked about the pain
behind the brave face I didn't think a
lot of people really understand what
that is
so perhaps you could just give us an
idea of what the last year's been like
it's hard you know I don't think anybody
could understand that Megan it was
unexpectedly candid in the doc
discussing postpartum life and the
British tabloids treatment of her since
her wedding to Harry my British friend
said to me
I'm sure he's great but you shouldn't do
it because the British tabloids will
destroy your life
and I very naively I'm an American we
don't have that bear what are you
talking about that doesn't make any
sense I'm gonna in tabloids and get it
so it's um yeah it's been complicated
now a lot of people jumped to Megan's
defence not many people have asked if
I'm okay but it's it's a very real thing
to be going through behind the scenes
but Wendy not so supportive no warrant
er some hatin ass girlfriend of hers I
like them I really do like them but her
there's something about her you know you
know what I'm saying
yes the takes were hot during hot topics
with Wendy saying that Megan should have
expected all of this negative attention
and you know that's the way it is but
make it Marlo nobody feel sorry for you
you knew what you were signing up for
girl
yeah Wendy went in no regrets
now the Sussex is have yet to respond to
Wendy's comments but we're also and not
expecting them to
[Music]